una pregunta que se han hecho muchos los
biólogos es como saben las plantas qué
hacer en las diferentes épocas del año y
bueno un mecanismo por el que pueden
saber en qué época del año estamos es
mediante el fotoperiodismo foto por luz
y periodo por duración duración de la
luz otra forma de verlo es que se basa
en la duración del día muchas plantas
saben cuándo florecer basándose en la
duración del día cuando los días son
largos y la planta florece se conocen
como plantas de días largos y algunas
otras flores crecen cuando el día es
corto así que esas son las plantas de
días cortos entonces la duración del día
parece está relacionada con la forma en
la que las plantas se regulan para
florecer pero cómo es que hace eso la
planta cómo es que responde con la
duración del día bueno se han hecho
diferentes experimentos y se ha
descubierto que por ejemplo
plantas de días cortos mejor les enseño
el experimento con plantas de días
cortos
miren resulta que las plantas de días
cortos bueno mejor primero veamos los
datos
antes de explicarles esto estas son las
horas del día aquí es medianoche y aquí
volvemos a medianoche y aquí podemos ver
que esta es una planta de día corto
porque cuando el día es corto sólo hay
luz durante 8 horas y la noche es más
larga
esta planta florece florece y por el
contrario cuando el día es largo y la
noche es corta no florece entonces esta
es una planta de días cortos
plantar de días cortos y una pregunta
muy interesante es será la duración del
día lo que determina si la planta
florece o es la duración de la noche
bueno resulta que muchas plantas de días
cortos al menos las que se han estudiado
hasta ahora si tenemos uno de esos días
cortos pero interrumpimos la noche sólo
un poco sólo unos minutos de luz solar
la planta no florecerá entonces una
conclusión que podemos sacar de esto es
que en realidad no depende mucho de la
duración del día porque si sólo fuera la
duración del día tendría sentido que aún
florecer pero más bien es la duración de
una noche sin interrupciones que tanto
dura una noche sin interrupciones de
algún tipo de luz entonces esto nos dice
que estas plantas de días cortos
dependen más de la duración de la noche
duración de la noche entonces podemos
pensar en una planta de días cortos como
una planta de noches largas pero como
sabemos y aquí podemos ver cuando
interrumpimos el día no pasa nada la
planta no empieza a florecer de repente
cuando ve que tiene un poco de
obscuridad porque el día se ha
interrumpido en algún momento entonces
cuando los experimentos se arrojan estos
resultados nos hace pensar en que al
menos para muchas plantas de días cortos
la duración de la noche es lo que
importa ahora para otro tipo de plantas
y recuerden de todo lo que les digo nada
es absoluto no quiere decir que todas
las plantas actúen de la misma forma
esto solo nos da una idea de los
diferentes mecanismos que podemos
encontrar en el mundo a nuestro
alrededor
entonces por ejemplo muchas plantas de
días largos en realidad florecen en el
día lo escribiré
tantas de días
y podemos separarlas en dos grupos están
las que dependen de la duración de la
noche de la noche una planta de días
largos que depende de la duración de la
noche se llama planta de noche corta
noche corta
y vamos a decir que este tipo de plantas
prefieren la oscuridad oscuridad
dominante
y existen otro tipo de plantas que
pueden florecer cuando los días son más
largos por ejemplo cuándo inicia el
verano y que dependen de la duración del
día y muchas veces no solamente es el
fotoperiodismo es decir no solamente es
la duración del día lo que determina
algún tipo de proceso biológico sino que
es la duración del día más otras cosas
que pueden tener algún efecto y en este
tipo de plantas en las que tenemos la
duración del día que es una señal
externa más otras señales tal vez
algunas sean señales biológicas internas
a esto se le conoce como modelo de
coincidencia externa porque los factores
externos tal vez coinciden con algo que
está ocurriendo y un ejemplo de eso es
una planta que produce micro
rn todos los días todos los días
conforme el día termina empieza a
producir micro arn
y esta es la planta arabidopsis entonces
la planta arabidopsis todos los días
produce bueno esto forma parte de los
ritmos circadianos que son simplemente
un ciclo diario aquí podemos ver que
empieza a producir mucho de este gen y
produce la proteína constante se o para
abreviar y una vez que estas proteínas
llegan a un cierto límite es cuando la
planta florece estoy simplificando mucho
el mecanismo como todos los mecanismos
biológicos que hemos visto en realidad
involucran muchas otras cosas pero esto
nos da una idea general entonces qué
pasa si bueno miren si esto ocurre todos
los días podemos decir que durante el
día los niveles de microarn son bajos
pero conforme transcurre el día los
niveles aumentan y se empieza a producir
esta proteína se producen muchas de
estas proteínas entonces porque la
planta no florece todos los días
bueno la respuesta es que cuando aumenta
la presencia de estas proteínas pero no
hay suficiente luz se degrada
naturalmente se degrada entonces en una
situación como esta suponiendo que es un
día corto esta planta no florecerá pero
si tuviéramos un día largo si tenemos un
día largo eso impide que estas proteínas
se degrade entonces en una situación de
un día largo supongamos que el día es
más largo las proteínas no se degradan
podemos suponer que la luz activa cosas
que protegen a estas proteínas y si
tenemos un día largo en este caso la
planta arabidopsis florecerá entonces la
idea principal de este vídeo es que nos
demos cuenta de que el fotoperiodismo
puede ser determinante para que una
planta pueda florecer o no y la
floración no es el único proceso
biológico afectado por la duración del
día y la duración del día no
la única forma de indicarle a una planta
qué día del año es o si debe regularse
muchas veces puede ser una combinación
de cosas a veces puede ser un ritmo
circadiano combinado con la duración del
día y también vimos que muchas veces lo
que importa más no es la duración del
día sino la duración de la noche